if you watch movies listen to music or
own a phone you're probably familiar
with subscriptions at least your wallet
is which four companies are pure gold or
green I guess instead of selling you
today and tomorrow and next week they
only need to convince you once and the
money keeps coming a steady predictable
stream of revenue because each customer
is so valuable they can focus more on
keeping them than doing anything and
everything to get more but it's no
longer just newspapers and magazines now
it's everything music movies food games
storage clothes razors makeup software
cars animal bones seriously
bone box includes the various
osteological specimens such as schools
claws and teeth for just $24.99 a month
ok why does every business need to be a
subscription where does it end let's
divide subscriptions into two categories
services like Netflix prime lootcrate
and Spotify kinda have to be
subscriptions sure you can buy music and
movies individually but here you get
everything forty million songs on Apple
music times the usual dollar twenty nine
would be 51 million dollars so yeah
subscription boxes which send you new
things in the mail every month are
services because they're more about fun
and surprise and the stuff itself and
then there are products things that
could be sold but here are rented and
this is where things get hairy you don't
have to be a master Googler or finger or
doctor goer but boy do those sound
awkward to find a million and a half
people criticizing this business model
but it's not actually subscriptions
they're angry about nobody's complaining
about Netflix or Spotify it's really
this second category especially software
when companies want to reach in your
wallet every month until you die for
what could be a simple one-time purchase
it feels a lot like a cash grab and
sometimes it totally is Adobe's switched
to a monthly fee precisely to increase
profit but it's not always so simple
even when they seem unnecessary
subscriptions can be good for everyone
including you and I companies usually
don't explain why and when they do it's
easy to see as
just an excuse to make more money but
there is a why and since my thing is
taking complicated controversial topics
and trying to explain them in too little
time let's get to it the idea of a
rental is nothing new we rent apartments
and cars and if you live in Alaska where
there are still six blockbusters movies
hashtags someone tell Alaska about
Netflix but nobody wants to rent say
their lamp when you don't have to why
would you owning is just simpler and
usually cheaper losing what we already
own is especially frustrating apps like
Ulysses and Autodesk were a one-time
purchase then one day you get an email I
know you already bought this but if you
want to keep getting updates now it
costs $5 a month okay thanks bye Ulysses
was absolutely flooded with one-star
reviews
probably the most life the Mac App Store
has ever seen and 50,000 people signed a
change.org petition against Adobe which
as we know is very effective at spamming
your email but here's the problem the
way most people think about software
just isn't realistic
remember that lamp what if every year
you got this popup hey you need to
update to a new version of your house if
you don't it'll be vulnerable to
burglars sometimes it goes smoothly
sometimes it permanently changes at your
wall sockets maybe to these cute little
ones from Denmark and you think what the
heck I bought that lamp and now it's
suddenly incompatible with my house for
reasons completely beyond my control the
house is your operating system the lamp
your software programming may seem like
build once collect profit forever but if
an app isn't updated it dies technology
just moves way too fast
knowing this do you really want to own
that lamp truly owning software means
owning all its bugs and future and
compatibility maybe your answer is yes
we'll get to that later but me if I
really depend on something and there's a
chance it'll break in a year well I'd
rather rent it from someone who
maintains it fixing bugs is like
Sisyphus endlessly pushing his Boulder
up the mountain only for it to fall back
down you can't expect developers to do
that forever just because you gave them
90
three years ago you might say obviously
these apps don't need subscriptions
because they did just find before but
the truth is they mostly didn't big
companies always find a way to earn a
profit adobe has the power and
prominence to ask fifty three dollars a
month and make billions doing it but
many apps some of the best apps are made
by a single person or a small team of
them they compete with two three million
others and a feeling that if you can't
hold something it shouldn't cost
anything so unless you trademark the
word candy
seriously that actually happened or
spend millions advertising your sales
look like this a huge spike in the
beginning maybe some seasonal bumps and
then almost nothing you might make half
your salary on the first day but by the
20th or 50th things don't look so good
so you have a few options you can get
more customers do some marketing keep
updating the app and cross your fingers
or more accurately pray to the app store
gods sometimes this can work but the App
Store isn't like YouTube doing
everything it can to bring audiences to
your videos right YouTube even a great
app can get stuck in a corner and never
be found and eventually everyone who
needs your app will already have it
plenty of happy customers and no more
income for you or if sales are so good
at the beginning just release as many
paid updates as possible again sometimes
it works but it can also be a dangerous
trap because the incentive is to release
as many paid updates as you can just
enough new features to make people pay
but not so many that you can't do it
again in a few months and sooner or
later it'll be good enough for 99% of us
but hey got to keep making money so
you'll keep cramming in new unnecessary
features that was Microsoft Office what
I asked from word is pretty basic when I
press a key on my keyboard I want that
same letter to show on my screen take
notes MacBook Pro keyboard and I guess
fonts and tables and images are cool too
but I have absolutely zero need for
three-d pie charts or smart tags or
research tools or talking paper clip
actually I take that last one back
Clippy office was so profitable
Microsoft just kept adding and adding
adding until it forgot word is just you
know a place to write stuff at this
point I'll just use Google Docs where I
actually know what the buttons do for
many apps neither option is sustainable
and even if you feel zero sympathy for
developers it's in your best interest to
find a solution because if you rely on
an app for your business or hobby or
security you want to incentivize its
developer to care just as much as you do
we can say companies should update their
apps forever and always answer support
tickets or we can design the system or
they actually want to form any apps
that's a subscription taking what you
would have paid up front and handing it
out over time if developers want to keep
getting paid they want to keep you happy
over time subscriptions cost more but
for that you're guaranteed updates and
support and compatibility plus it
rewards the apps you use the longest in
some industries these better incentives
are even more desperately needed for
news companies the goal is more clicks
more views more ads usually the worst
kinds of ads clickbait only stops if
click stop being profitable which is the
promise of subscriptions like Blundell
and inkle one price for all the articles
you want or a small micro payment per
article refunded if it turns out to be
clickbait the goal is no longer to
deceive you but keep you subscribed
subscriptions give sites like above
Avalon Kottke and Mac stories freedom to
make quality content on really specific
topics instead of whatever it takes to
attract huge audiences it also lets you
and I try things out maybe you only need
a service occasionally in which case you
can subscribe only when you actually
need it but because people think only of
services as subscriptions products often
try to argue they're actually a service
something like we store and sync your
data which costs us money but not very
much
all this does is create distrust
developers should be upfront what you're
really paying for is longevity which is
in everyone's best interest but there is
a catch
one movie ticket is an entire month of
Netflix and then some factor in popcorn
savings and make it a lifetime you could
own one single album or every noise ever
made on planet Earth for the price of a
few cups of coffee but when everything
is the price of one or two cups of
coffee you can very quickly end up
buying a whole Starbucks say you
subscribe to Netflix Amazon Prime
Spotify Dropbox and blue apron that's
over a hundred dollars a month
add Creative Cloud YouTube TV and the
New York Times and it's another hundred
and this is just the beginning Apple
takes 30% of an app's revenue but for
long term subscriptions now only 15 so
more and more businesses are going to
make use for movies alone there's
already Netflix Amazon Hulu HBO Showtime
and soon Disney and Apple so not
everything can or should be a
subscription things you use only
occasionally and don't rely on have no
reason to be or should at least have
another option for people who fall into
that category the app sketch finds a
good balance one upfront price with one
year of updates you can treat it like a
subscription or you can not another
solution is bundles one price from
multiple subscriptions set up for
example does this with Mac applications
and more companies will follow Apple
could have one for Apple music streaming
video iCloud storage maybe some other
things
Amazon Prime has shown how well this
strategy can work students get Spotify
and Hulu together for less than either
separately or how about a subscription
to be a great student on topics like
physics computer science and problem
solving brilliant helps you learn new
things in a way that you actually
understand not just memorized for the
next test last term I took a math class
covering some differential equations all
pretty vague and theoretical but after
looking at the lesson on brilliant I
really wish I had known about it it
starts by explaining why the concept
actually matters and what it's all about
with the visuals and questions to give
you instant feedback if you answer
incorrectly brilliant doesn't just mark
your answer red and move on it helps you
understand how to get it right if you're
a student or like learning new things
find a topic that piques your interest
and die
in I recommend a computer science
algorithms it's pretty interesting and
gives you a peek at how our technology
works
and speaking of subscriptions it's
really the ideal premium is one low
price they keep adding new topics all
the time and you have the freedom to
jump around to learn exactly what
interests you the most you can support
poly matter by going to the link in the
description
brilliant org slash poly matter and the
first 200 people to use that will get
20% off the annual premium subscription
thanks to brilliant and to everyone who
gives it a try